à quelques heures du coup d'envoi des
soldes d'hiver 2010 est les magasins
s'activent pour préparer ce rendez vous
dans cette boutique implantée dans le
centre-ville de maurepas spécialisé dans
le prêt-à-porter les vendeuses ont
commencé les préparatifs depuis une
semaine
donc là je vais étiqueter les produits
donc je fais très attention au prix de
pas me tromper dans les dents les pulls
et l'âge étiquette comme ceci avec un
pistolet cet appareil ça s'appelle un
pistolet pour étiqueter et je mets bien
mon prix soldes bien en avant pour que
la cliente voit tout de suite qu'il est
soldé et derrière c'est indiqué 30%
ça c'est très important faut tout soit
indiquée en plus des traditionnels
pancartes des stickers et des étiquettes
sur les vêtements la boutique utilise un
système de mailing pour rappeler à ses
clients la date des soldes et pour
donner toutes les informations sur ces
produits
j'ai marqué n'attendez pas les soldes
mois 20 mois 50 % et après j'en vois je
fais par dix à vingt cliente j'ai plus
de 700 cliente par mail donc je vais
envoyer à toutes mes clientes toute la
matinée
même rituel pour cette boutique de
l'espace saint quentin les étiquettes
rouges sont de sortie tout est presque
prêt pour demain matin un seul mot
n'apparaît pas le mot soldes sous peine
d'une amende comprise entre 15000 et
75000 euros jusqu'au 11
le onze c'est vraiment le jour des
soldes pour ce mot à peu apparaître
on a un service juridique qui est là
pour nous protéger
qu'on ne commettent pas d'erreurs si
jamais il ya un agent de la dgccrf qui
passe on reste dans la loi donc mon
affiche des tarifs puisqu'il ya l'offre
donc pour nous au moins 50% jusqu'à -50%
pour deux produits achetés avec des
étiquettes rouges mais il n'y a pas de
mot soldes qui apparaît donc on
on va gagner du temps là je pense
aujourd'hui sur les préparatifs un temps
précieux pour préparer au mieux lui des
semaines les plus chargés de l'année
pour les commerçants pour répondre à
cette demande la boutique ouvriraient à
8h30
une heure plus tôt que d'habitude